[Music]
good evening I'm Kevin Kelly with the
long now foundation a stewart brand is
absent he's on a field trip to the site
of the lung
now clock and I'll be your host for this
evening the next talk that we have is
actually this month we usually have this
one a month but we have actually two in
May this May the next speaker is Paul
Romer the economist who will be speaking
on May 18th and also bring to your
attention if you like this talk you
might be interested in the one on July
28th pamela ronald and raoul Adamo talk
who are talking about organically grown
and genetically engineered food for the
future so our speaker tonight is is
Michael Pollan he'll be signing books
copies of his in defense of food paper
back out here at the end of the talk he
also will be appearing in a documentary
called Food Inc which will be shown I
think sometime in June first week of
June or so he appears in that and he
also will be talking to us tonight about
deep agriculture so well now is is about
trying to think in terms of long-term
thinking and that's not often done with
food food is the system we'd like to
take a systems view of it and that's
what Michael Pollan actually is an
expert at thinking about the kind of
systemic view of food through time but
also unlike people who think
systematically he also thinks about it
with his heart he's a food lover and
that combination is actually very rare
of taking both the immediate view and
the long view and with that I like you
to welcome excuse me Michael Pollan
[Music]
thank you
thank you very much thank you Kevin
they want you backstage to fix your
microphone thanks a lot thanks for
coming tonight it really is a special
honor to be invited into this community
and I'm very appreciative I looked at
the list of past speakers and many of my
heroes so it's and a little bit
surprising because I think people don't
think of food and farming is about the
future so much is the past generally
certainly that was the the common view
of agriculture in our society till very
very recently it was kind of yesterday's
news you know about as sexy as Green
Acres or Beverly Hillbillies or the the
CBS primetime lineup up until a few
years ago but that's clearly changed how
we feed ourselves today goes right to
the biggest questions of our time and
that's what I want to talk about farming
is almost cool hardly a week goes by and
I'm not exaggerating where I meet a
software developer who's you know taking
his options and and and buying a farm so
what I'd like to do today I'm gonna talk
for about 40 45 minutes and then take
your questions and I look forward to
hearing them but I want to offer a kind
of state of the movement address talk a
little bit about where we are because
we're at this very interesting fulcrum
moment I think of change around food and
where we need to go long term those of
us who've been working for many years to
reform the food system and the American
Way of eating we suddenly find ourselves
in a very odd and in some ways exciting
but also uncomfortable new place no
longer holding a sign outside on the
granite steps of the USDA or or the
Capitol but inside with the seat at the
table challenge now is to figure out
what to say I want to start out with a
little quiz I'm gonna read you a quote
and you tell me or try to tell me which
well-known critic of the American food
system said this
here's how it goes our entire
agricultural system is built on cheap
oil as a consequence our agriculture
sector actually is contributing more
greenhouse gases than our transportation
sector and in the meantime it's creating
monocultures that are vulnerable to
national security threats that are also
now vulnerable to sky-high food prices
or crashes and food prices huge swings
and commodity prices and are partly
responsible for the explosion in our
health care costs because they're
contributing to type-2 diabetes stroke
and heart disease obesity all the things
that are driving our huge explosion in
healthcare cost
costs any idea who said that yeah
President Obama said that isn't that
kind of amazing
what that tells us is that we have a
president and we know he's a supreme dot
connector right in many ways but he's
he's a very good dot connector in the
food system and that he has made the
links between the way we grow our food
and the healthcare crisis on the one
hand and the energy and climate change
crisis on the other that's a very big
connection to draw and it has it has
tremendous implications so we have a
president who understands this these
issues we actually have a Secretary of
Agriculture who appeared Tom Vilsack who
appears to be charged with a mandate for
reform we don't know how far that's
going to go although we do know his
number two a woman named Kathleen
Merrigan who's very closely identified
with with writing the organic rules and
is a devoted reformer is running the
Department of Agriculture that's kind of
mind-blowing and then of course we have
Michelle Obama who so far may be doing
the most important thing of all which is
to say talking about real food planting
a garden a garden she took pains to tell
the media was an organic garden she
didn't have to take that extra step and
you know it really pissed off the the
crop protection industry as they
currently like to call themselves they
they wrote her a letter actually it was
kind of it was polite but pointed about
you know we really think by making this
garden organic you have cast aspersions
on on conventional food in our industry
and we really hope you will consider
buying and using some of our you know
wonderful crop protection products
anyway so all that is very exciting it's
given a huge boost I think to the
movement and and indeed to home
gardening if you've tried to buy garden
seeds you know you go to your garden
center and you will find you know kind
of holes missing teeth in that great
wall of of seed packets but the it the
question still remains
is there a mandate for real change
is Obama prepared to use his
considerable political capital on this
issue and do we have a path that will
take us from where we are to where we
want to be Obama certainly did not run
on a platform of reforming food and
agriculture yet my argument tonight is
that sooner or later first term or more
likely second term he will find himself
forced to deal with the food system
because he will have a lot of trouble he
will discover making significant
progress on health care costs or climate
change or energy independence without
tackling the food system because it is
the shadow problem over all those those
three other problems and the way we're
feeding ourselves is at the heart of all
three issues consider these a couple
stats the food system as that quote
indicated and this news has reached
Obama but the food system as a whole
that's agriculture and food processing
uses more fossil fuel about 20% of the
total and contributes more greenhouse
gases not just co2 but methane and
nitrous oxide from fertilizer to the
atmosphere than any other industry
somewhere depending on the studies and
none of them are reliable between 17 and
34 percent of greenhouse gas is
traceable to the way we're eating the
industrialization of American
agriculture over the past 50 years has
transformed it from a system that used
to produce to calories of food energy
for every one calorie of fossil fuel
energy because you know calories are
just energy right you can have food
calories you can have fossil fuel
calories so two calories you would get
two calories of food for every calorie
of fossil fuel you put into the system
to a system where today it takes ten
calories of fossil-fuel energy to
produce one calorie of food that you
know if you know when we use this word
unsustainable which is a vexed
complicated word often misused i I think
that
it's a pretty good case for an
unsustainable industry given what we
know about the future of fossil fuel and
then there are many worse cases than
that feedlot beef your McDonald's
hamburger if it's fed from corn that's
been fed from fossil fuel is even worse
55 calories of fossil fuel energy to
bring one calorie of food to the table
so when we eat from the modern
industrial food system and this is the
key point we are eating oil and spewing
greenhouse gas which is kind of crazy
when you recall that every calorie we
eat is ultimately the product of
photosynthesis that is the only way to
get food energy off of this planet is
sunlight feeding plants plants turning
that light a couple simple minerals and
carbon dioxide into edible calories it's
the only way to do it and if you're
eating meat you're eating the result of
photosynthesis and in the feed and if
you're eating fish you're eating the
result of photosynthesis and the algae
at the bottom of that food chain so it's
the only way to do it
food is the original solar technology
and there is I think enormous hope in
that simple fact now let's turn our
attention briefly to healthcare crisis
since 1960 when I was a boy spending on
healthcare in this country has risen
from five percent of national income to
18 percent we won't be able to insure
everyone in this country unless we get
those costs under control now there are
many reasons for high health care costs
but one of the biggest and perhaps the
biggest if you listen to the CDC is the
cost of preventable chronic diseases
linked to diet four of the top 10
killers are chronic diseases linked to
diet two thirds of heart disease can be
traced to diet 40 percent of cancer can
be traced to diet most of type 2
diabetes most of obesity obviously CDC
estimates that of the two trillion
dollars we're spending on health care
today
1.5 trillion three-quarters goes to
treat preventable chronic disease and
this doesn't even
include the cost of antibiotic resistant
diseases that are coming off of our
feedlots or the effects of agricultural
pollution now is it just a coincidence
that in these years that health care
costs were soaring from five percent of
national income to eighteen percent say
it's between 17 and 18 percent the cost
the percentage of our personal income we
spent on food plummeted from 18 percent
to nine and a half percent so you see as
we have spent less on food we have spent
more on health care which suggests that
cheap food perhaps has some hidden costs
so that's the bad news our food system
is broken we probably can't afford to
keep on eating this way cheap food has
cost us dearly and our agricultural
policies are largely responsible the
intention of those policies and and I
can't emphasize too much the extent to
which the food system we have is the
result of the incentive system we
created around food for our farmers for
our processors the food system we have
is not the result of the free market
it's not the result of nature there is
nothing it's inevitable about it it's
very evident
and it is that's a real word and there
is so we have to pay attention to policy
and we will as we go through this so
that's the bad news
the the good news is though that food is
this original solar technology if
there's any part of the economy we
should be able to re solar eyes you
would think it is food we are as a
society I think coming to a very
important recognition and that is that
you cannot have a healthy population
without a healthy diet I think that's
generally accepted what's less well
known but equally important and I think
is dawning is the idea that you cannot
have a healthy diet without a healthy
agriculture that these two things are
intimately linked and there is no way to
protect yourself merely by getting the
right nutrients eating the right things
from a sick food chain that really
doesn't work so the good news is that
Americans increasingly sense that this
system is broken we have leaders who
understand that is broken a movement for
reform is building and the market for
alternative kinds of food whether you're
talking about organic or pasture based
or local is booming the even better news
is this the same policies that will
reduce Agriculture's contribution to
climate change and the energy crisis
will also dramatically improve public
health there is no issue of trade-offs
this is not a zero sum this is one of
those lucky issues that is not zero-sum
we can make progress on all these fronts
at once make the system safer more
secure more sustainable and tastier not
only here in America but in the
developing world as well well I think we
won't be able to do again is make food
as cheap as it has been or something we
can ever take for granted again now food
reform you know that's a big chaotic
subject means a lot of different things
to different people and you've got lots
of people in this movement working at in
their own little fiefs I mean you've got
people working on school lunch very
important work you people working on
labeling you have people working on
building local food economies bringing
food to food deserts in the inner cities
you know getting the trans fats out of
the food out of food you know all these
different kind of elements and it is a
little inchoate as a movement and and
that's why when I use this term movement
some people are kind of surprised but
there's very little in the way of
organizing ideas big simple ideas that
that will knit these people together and
that's what I want to talk about the big
picture and the virtues of a big guiding
idea is that it can help you judge all
the smaller ideas all the proposals all
the new technologies that come along are
they moving you in the direction of your
big idea or away from it
we have policies we you know we have
personal policies but we have public
policies so we don't have to rethink
every question that comes up so I want
to lay out that big idea a long-term
framework for reform and this is a
process I began in an article you may
have read farmer in chief in the New
York Times last fall at a time and I
didn't know who the farmer in chief
would be a key feature of this idea is
as I said it's not zero-sum it does not
pit rural farmers against urban eaters
or the interests of health and the
environment against the interest of
American farmers here's the core idea
we need to wean the American food system
off it's heavy
20th century diet of fossil fuels and
put it back on a diet of contemporary
sunshine that's basically it easier said
than done of course it will require
changes at every link in the food chain
that connects you to the soil that
you're eating from changes at the level
of the farm the marketplace and the
culture and I want to walk through those
three levels but we do know this the Sun
still shines very brightly brighter than
ever in fact if any part of the modern
economy can be solarized it should be
food now I want to just very briefly run
through how we got here this idea that
we're eating fossil fuel is not
immediately apparent basically when we
began industrializing agriculture which
is you know begins before World War two
but really takes off with World War two
what we were doing another way to phrase
that is we were taking labour out of the
farm and replacing it with fossil fuel
and technology so that all the big
innovations not all of them most of the
big innovations in agriculture such as
ammonium nitrate fertilizer pesticides
most of which are made from petroleum
were basically fossil fuel products and
they were very much the products of
World War two we took the munitions
ammonium nitrate is bomb fuel as we
learned in in Omaha know in Oklahoma
Oklahoma City a few years ago and we
converted that to
a fertilizer the same factories that
were making bombs one day on a given day
in the 1947 began making fertilizer in
great quantities Vandana Shiva says that
we are still eating the leftovers of
World War two and that's what she means
we're eating the result of that
conversion of fertilizer and nerve gases
which became our pesticides those those
those grew out of research into how to
kill people and we found that in tiny
doses they kill bugs pretty reliably now
the reason what those technologies allow
you to do is something that that doesn't
happen in nature very much and that is
monocultures very large fields of the
same thing which have certain advantages
a monoculture can be at you know in a
very simple sense inefficient technology
and these are technologies one tractor
one pass can harvest a whole field of
corn one corn planter can can can plant
18 or 36 rows at the same time so moving
from diversity to this monoculture
allowed you to greatly increase
production but you couldn't do it
without these technologies because if
you kept if you just had corn upon corn
upon corn you would deplete your soil
but ammonium nitrate fertilizer sources
of nitrogen allowed you to replenish the
soil from a back monocultures are also
supremely vulnerable to pests you will
build up a huge population of the pests
of whatever you know of your corn or
your soy or whatever it is so you can't
have a monoculture without pesticides to
defend them and this worked really well
it still works really well from one
measure and we need to acknowledge the
achievement of this system which is that
put one way you can walk into a fast
food outlet and you can get yourself two
or three thousand calories of food you
know a day's worth for less than the
minimum wage for one hour now if you
think about it in the long course of
human history where people have put so
much time and effort into keeping
themselves fed
this is an amazing achievement it just
happens to have come at a very high cost
so but we should acknowledge that and
this has been our policy we have
rewarded farmers for planting
monocultures we only subsidized five
crops if you are a corn farmer we'll
give you money to grow corn and soy but
if you want to put in a row of broccoli
that land is permanently ineligible for
subsidies okay we it's illegal for you
to diversify your farm under our current
agriculture policies we wanted to
encourage this robust the the great
1970s era AG secretary said you know
plant fence row to fence row get bigger
get out and this was our goal it was our
goal because the public's interest was
in having more cheap calories and we
need to remember when we started I'm
trying to be as sympathetic to this
regime as I can that you know early in
the 20th century the big public health
problem was people were hungry even
Kennedy when he you know looked at
poverty found money you know great deal
of rural hunger and urban hunger so we
asked our farmers to solve the great
public health problem of that time which
was we need more cheap calories and they
did it they did a brilliant job the
challenge today is to once again align
the public interest with the work of
farmers because I'm convinced that
American farmers can do whatever we ask
them to as a society we just need to ask
them for something a little different
fossil fuel played other roles in the
system it allowed us to nationalize the
system we could move food from
California with refrigerated trucks all
the way to New York and we began doing
that fossil fuel pump the water and the
irrigation systems fossil fuel is what
allows us today to have these you know
really crazy supply chains I mean we are
we are catching salmon sustainably
Native Americans are catching salmon
sustainably in Alaska it is then being
flown to China to be filleted and then
flown back to California to be eaten so
when you see that sustainable salmon at
Whole Foods
you have to you have to realize what
hasn't been counted we you know
California now feeds New York that's an
amazing idea
Iowa imports 90% of its food this is the
best soil in the world does not feed
Iowa because they export raw material
corn and so I gets turned into processed
food they buy it back I was a food
desert by and large um we you know we as
Herman daily pointed out we we import
sugar cookies from Denmark and we export
sugar cookies to Denmark and he said you
know it might be a good idea to swap
recipes instead but this system will not
go on indefinitely something very
interesting happened last summer when
fuel prices got as high as they got the
cost of shipping a box of broccoli from
from Salinas Valley to the Hunts Point
Market in the Bronx went from $3 a box
to $10 a box price of broccoli went went
through the roof in New York and what
happened when it hit that price was very
interesting you had companies like
Tamara and Antle and the big growers and
Packers in the Central Valley buying
farmland in New England because they saw
the writing on the wall they saw that
you know this is crazy we're not going
to be able to ship produce across the
country indefinitely we are gonna have
to figure out a way to grow food nearer
to where people live that they will be
doing it and not New England farmers is
is is it tragedy I think but hopefully
the New England farmers will get in on
that deal so I think we understand that
we're in this little moment of cheap
fossil fuel and that whatever you think
of the system however much you like it
it depends on that fossil fuel and
cannot survive it getting expensive
again so the challenge is then how do
you get this system off of oil which is
so deeply implicated and by the way it's
most implicated in the fact that we have
no farmers left we only have a million
full-time farmers in this country 305
million people are being fed by 1
million that's astounding
these are the most productive humans who
have ever lived
one Iowa farmer they are one Iowa farmer
feeds about a hundred and fifty of his
neighbors and that has never been the
case and it probably can't continue
because it all depends on cheap fossil
fuel so how do you get your system off
of of cheap fossil fuel that's what I
want to walk you through you need
radical reforms at three levels reforms
that are going to take a long time
reforms that have some serious obstacles
before them
the first is on the farm I want to talk
a little bit about agriculture you know
the key to getting farms off of fossil
fuel is figuring out how you produce
lots of biomass without without it right
amazingly enough nature produces huge
amounts of biomass every year without
fossil fuels without pesticides without
fertilizers how so how does it do it and
we have understood this for a long time
in fact some of the intellectual history
of this organization dovetails with that
knowledge and that is in 1971 and this
really is the beginning of the modern
food movement I think Wendell Berry
published an article in the Whole Earth
Catalog introducing Americans to the
work of Sir Albert Howard in English
agronomist who'd spent a lot of time in
India studying peasant Agriculture's in
the 30s and he explained that the way
you did it was you modeled your system
on nature whether you're talking about a
forest or a prairie these systems were
sustainable they renewed their fertility
they had cycles of growth and decay and
they dealt with pests through
biodiversity through many many species
you did not find monocultures in nature
and that has basically been the core
idea since then of of organic
agriculture how do you mimic how do you
best mimic those systems and move from
monoculture to poly culture which is to
say growing many crops in rotation or
symbiotically the power to produce huge
amounts of food from such systems has
been proven
producing huge amounts of foods
basically from sunlight soil and water
at very different scales and I've
written about some but if you read
Omnivore's Dilemma I described Joel
Salatin remarkable farm which is now has
many many imitators in California this
orchestrated five species dance of
creatures that produces huge amounts of
meat from very little land but we but we
have proof that you can do this at large
scales too and one interesting case is
Argentina where you have farms of five
and ten thousand acres bigger even than
the farms you find in Iowa today or
Nebraska and they have this very clever
rotation which is to say that they graze
ruminants mostly cattle on grass for
five years rotationally and this grazing
builds up so much fertility in the soil
so much carbon in the soil that they can
then plow that those pastures those
perennial pastures and get three years
of grain corn soy whatever they want
without any fertilizer whatsoever
without any pesticides because the weeds
that would be a problem in the pastures
can't survive tillage and the weeds that
would be a problem in tilled fields
can't survive years of perennial so we
know you can do this and a lot of it
depends on redefining our sense of what
a clever technology is and what I
suggest is that a really smart rotation
like that eight-year rotation in
Argentina is as clever and powerful of
technology as the latest genetically
modified seed and we need to look at it
that way the question is why don't we
look at it that way well by and large
because there's nothing to sell in the
case of the rotation and what makes
agriculture really work in a sustainable
direction are processes more than
products which is why there's very
little Rd that goes into developing
these technologies so one of the things
we need to do is is shift our research
agenda in that direction and
not count on private companies who will
not be able to figure out a way to lock
up the intellectual property of a really
good relation relationship between
chickens and and cows and pigs on a farm
so that's one thing we need to research
we need to shift the whole research
agenda the government though as I
suggested subsidized this whole move
toward strict monocultures and there is
no reason why with a different set of
policies changing the incentives we
can't move agriculture back there is one
reason why actually I'll get to that we
should for example instead of right now
are our subsidies reward farmers by the
bushel how much can they grow of these
five crops that we subsidize we could
reward them instead for diversification
for how many different crops do you have
well pay you more for every one you add
to the rotation or we'll pay you to plan
a cover crop in the fall which very few
farmers do today cover crops by
themselves
another great technology completely
unglamorous what you know what they do
is they keep soil from eroding over the
winter when it's lots of snow on it they
they they build up carbon in the soil
farmers don't do it why not well they
usually get a break if they spray their
fertilizer in the fall because the
fertilizer spreaders aren't as busy as
they are in the spring and they they
want to they have a whole lot of reasons
they have to do with their convenience
and the fact that they're not rewarded
for doing it
nothing could do more to clean up the
Gulf of Mexico than cover crops in Iowa
and places like that fertility you know
in the same way that cheap oil is a
curse because it leads to profligate use
cheap nitrogen has been a curse to and
that there shouldn't be such cheap
nitrogen and there won't be when fossil
fuel prices get high it quadrupled in
price during the oil spike but we also
need municipal composting we need we
need mandatory composting in our cities
to generate compost to bring back to our
farms I mean we're really just you know
throwing out all the fertility that
we're growing to diversify farms to
really close this nutrient loop you need
to put animals back on farms one of the
things our subsidies did was allow
farmers to
sell their grain below the cost of
production and this sucked all the
animals off of America's farms and put
them on feedlots because the feedlot
operator could buy grain more cheaply
than a farmer could grow it so it'd be
come on it became uh neck anomic for
farmers to have animals on their farms
this was a disaster from an
environmental point of view and I would
argue from a cultural point of view as
well when you take animals off of farms
and put them on feed Lots you are taking
this is Wendell Berry's line you're
taking a brilliant solution which is to
say the animals consume crop waste and
give you fertility and the plants feed
the animals and get fertility from the
animals you take this brilliant solution
technology to and you neatly divided it
into two problems you have a fertility
shortage on the farm where the crops are
being raised that you remedy with fossil
fuel fertilizers and then you have a
fertility surplus on the feed Lots where
you have these manure lagoons where
we're breeding things like swine flu
that you know this you would think
farmers would die for this stuff no they
don't want it it's got too many
pharmaceuticals in it it's got too much
phosphorus in it and so it's it's
they're releasing methane and nitrous
oxide into the air so getting animals
back on farms very very important we
should be subsidizing our farmers and I
do believe we should subsidize farmers
by the way I don't think the answer is
to go to a free market system in
agriculture we it has never worked in
any recorded civilization farming is is
subject to crises of overproduction that
are just unavoidable we can talk about
that later if you want but what we
should pay them for again is to is for
fulfilling the interests of the public
which we're not doing we're out of phase
they were they did a good job they did
what we asked them to do now let's ask
them for something else and what should
we ask them for well the one big thing I
would ask them for is sequestering
carbon take the 700 million acres of
farm and ranch land and manage it in
such a way that it is taking carbon out
of the air estimates are between 10 and
15 percent of
atmospheric carbon could be returned to
the soil with sustainable agricultural
practices I'm delighted to hear Al Gore
talking about this issue for the first
time as part of the solution and there
are ways we could do that we have to
learn how to measure carbon better we
have to figure out the best ways to do
it but we know rotational grazing where
you move the animals every day produces
huge amounts of carbon in the soil I can
explain how later we know that organic
agriculture compared to conventional
agriculture builds up the carbon in the
soil we know how to do this we have to
figure out how to measure it and how to
reward farmers for it and one of my big
concerns about this cap-and-trade scheme
is that the first bill to emerge from
Henry Waxman's committee simply left
agriculture out we are not going to get
a handle on climate change by ignoring
agriculture not when it represents the
third of the problem why did they leave
agriculture out because that's what big
AG wanted them to do they don't want to
be involved because in addition to the
carrots of paying farmers for
sequestering carbon or generating you
know energy you need sticks as well you
need to take Tulare County where vast
amounts of methane and nitrous oxide are
leaving these huge cattle confinement
operations and make them pay for that in
the same way that power plants are going
to pay for their emissions so you need
carrots and sticks in agriculture and
nothing could do more to drive the whole
system change that we're talking about
than that but you should also be
rewarding farmers for creating bee
habitat we have a crisis of the
honeybees right now that is the result
of monoculture so let's reward them for
taking out a row of almonds every you
know 50 thousand rows and put in a row
of flowers of perennials so that the
bees stick around for the whole year
we should reward farmers for generating
electricity for wind energy we should
and this might sound weird one of the
most important functions of Agriculture
is to keep cities in check stopping
sprawl we should reward farms in
critical areas as as as bulwarks against
sprawl so again the basic goal is to
realign the public interest what do we
need as a society and
then reward farmers for giving that to
us
now I said that there was an obstacle
and the biggest obstacle to what I'm
describing his labor we don't have
enough farmers I don't think to grow
sustainably I said we were down to about
a million that's not enough and as
fossil fuel gets expensive or runs out
we're gonna need more people on the land
it's hard to imagine 20 or 30 more
million people on the land in this
country I actually think it's easier to
move developing world agriculture in a
sustainable direction as much as
Monsanto wants to you know bring their
seeds to Africa I think that it is a
place where these kind of systems would
work really really well because you
still have a lot of people on the land
and industrializing agriculture there
and driving them to the city seems like
not a smart idea but what do we do here
well we have to encourage the the many
people the many young people today who
do want to farm make it possible make
cheap land available to them make an
education in agriculture available to
them and there's signs that this is
happening for the first time the the new
agriculture census that it's done every
five years found an uptick in the number
of farmers in America the first time in
history about a hundred thousand new
farmers today over five years ago very
small farmers local farms people at
farmer's markets CSAs so we have to make
farming cool we have to make it pay well
to encourage people to go back to the
land and the last thing we have to do on
the farm is preserve farmland near our
cities that is one of the most important
most endangered resources we have we are
lucky in San Francisco that you don't
have to travel hundreds of miles to get
to good farmland but we have to make
sure it stays this way in the same way
that if you want to develop a wetland
you have to meet a very high bar of
proof that is absolutely necessary and
you will be strongly discouraged from
doing it the same should hold true for
prime a one farmland that you should
have to provide a food system impact
statement before you're allowed to
develop it because once houses go up on
this land
it will never be formed again I say that
although I just heard about a there's a
environmental group that is actually
bulldozing defunct real estate
developments in the Central Valley now
so I might be wrong about that the Trust
for Public Land is involved in a big
project to actually return a subdivision
to parkland but the next step is
farmland and we should incorporate farms
in our development schemes we should
reward developers in the same way we
reward them for for you know open space
we should reward them for including
farms I mean what if we had farms in the
middle of all those subdivisions instead
of golf courses would that be great with
CSAs with anyway so that's the last
point on farms now you asked can we feed
the world this way this is the big
question I get asked this all the time
and I'll tell you the really honest
answer I I don't know I really don't
know but the reason I don't know is we
haven't tried and a lot of people are
prepared to give up before we try I also
know that there is a whole lot of slack
in this system half of the grain we grow
in the world is going to feed animals
and that the great slack is of course
meat-eating worldwide I also know that a
quarter of the food we're growing is
simply wasted so there is probably
enough land to grow all the food we need
for the 10 billion that are coming the
labor I think is really the big question
um but you know before people it's so
interesting how people are just they
raise this question and then they turn
to Monsanto and you know we by the same
token we we don't know if we can run an
industrial civilization without cheap
fossil fuel we don't know if we can do
that either but we know we have to try
we know we have to try and the same goes
for food and it's not all or nothing you
commit yourself you move in that
direction you shift the research agenda
we have the models and what we need are
the people and the commitment to
now level two I'm gonna go a little
faster through level two and three if
the farms diversify you know somebody's
got to buy that stuff if they move to
five crops in Iowan there's nobody left
to eat food in Iowa that's not going to
work right now the grain elevator only
will buy corn and soy if you live in
Iowa so we need to diversify the food
marketplace we need to build a real
local food infrastructure we need four
seasons' farmers markets in every town
in America not expensive buildings as
soon as you had farmers markets that
were not simply seasonal and we have to
remember the idea of a 50 week farmers
market that we're all spoiled on here in
California is is quite rare in the rest
of the world but if you had indoor
structures beautiful structures like the
Boqueria in Barcelona and Europe is full
of these structures you would have
farmers growing produce under glass more
root vegetables and more meat and cheese
and all that kind of food would show up
in those markets so that's I think is a
very important thing we need to do we
the basic premise though here is we need
to decentralize the food system now you
say that might be a little less
efficient and I will concede it is less
efficient but one of the most important
lessons I think of the last few years is
that as important of value as efficiency
is resilience finally is a more
important value in efficient systems by
definition are not resilient because
resiliency depends on redundancy right
and by definition that is inefficient to
do things to you know twice so the
advantages of decentralizing the food
system are many though it will reduce
fossil fuel consumption but more
important the system can better
withstand shocks and the only thing we
can be sure of going forward is that
there will be shocks oil price shocks
weather shocks pathogen shocks terrorism
shocks and one of the the real
vulnerabilities of our food system of
this national food chain based on
monoculture is based on only four
companies selling all the beef three
grain traders you know
incredibly cinched waist economy of this
food system is that it is exquisitely
vulnerable to accidental or deliberate
contamination we learned this after 9/11
the government went and was looking for
all the different vulnerabilities in our
society and the GAO did a report
Government Accounting Office and they
said one of the biggest vulnerabilities
of all is the food system we have a
single hamburger grinding plant that's
feeding 50 million people over the
course of a month we have a single
lettuce washing facility that's doing 26
million servings of salad every week a
single canister a poison introduced into
those systems could kill huge amounts of
people and the government saw this
threat and said well yes we have a
problem with centralized food production
in this country and then buried it
because nobody wanted to go there nobody
wanted to go there but we need to go
there and if we if we reload the food
system we will be eating more real food
because this system of monocultures
feeds into a system of heavily processed
food that can you know the deathless
Twinkie that lasts you know on the shelf
for two years it's very much tied to the
system I'm describing so the market is
pushing things in this direction there
is an incredible ferment lots of effort
to real ouka lies food but the
government can do a lot to encourage it
and to get out of the way in some ways
they need to deregulate small food
processors who you know I talked to
farmers all the time or growing
wonderful pork but they're not allowed
to smoke a ham without having a hundred
thousand dollars of facility because the
rules are designed for Hormel and and
the little farmer with his you know
couple hams simply can't afford to to be
in that system we need antitrust
enforcement that this food system is so
heavily concentrated that even if we
just went back to the level of antitrust
enforcement of Dwight Eisenhower we
would have a completely different food
system than we have now I think the most
important thing the government can do to
create a
you know a renaissance of local food
production and consumption would be
simply to regionalize food procurement
just you know pass a law in the same way
we have a law that a certain amount of
procurement for force a military
contractors has to go to minority
contractors because that satisfies a
public goal well what if one or two
percent of all the money the government
spends on on military bases on prisons
on schools went to local food production
food grown within a hundred miles that
would do it just that two percent it's
all we need
and we also need to develop urban AG
because there are lots of places where
food can be grown in cities and one of
the most exciting things happening in
this food movement that I didn't mention
earlier is what's happening in our
cities if you go to Detroit there's a
there's an amazing project there to feed
the city from the city Will Allen is a
visionary farmer in inner-city Milwaukee
who's growing huge amounts of food on
two acres in the middle of Milwaukee and
has plans to feed 10% of that city from
his farm so we need to support that kind
of work and there's evidence that this
government will be supporting that I
think we barely begun to test the
potential of urban agriculture to deal
with these food deserts which are such a
big part of the public health problem so
that's level two the economy there's a
lot we can do it's not that expensive it
just takes a commitment on the part of
the government and a food industry that
is willing to allow it to happen
and that may be the hard obstacle there
and level three is the food culture the
fact is I've described this as a supply
driven problem that we have all this
cheap calories coming off the farms that
gets turned into processed food that we
eat it ruins our health
it ruins the land it really has ruined
the occupation of farming for so many
people well we are all implicated in the
culture of fast cheap and easy food if
you look at the numbers for this food
industry we spent about eight hundred
and eighty-one billion dollars on food
every year you know how much of that
gets back to the farmers they clear
about 69 billion of that
okay it's a tiny tiny amount and 14
billion of what they're clearing is
subsidies just to give you an idea the
people who make the packages the
cellophane and the cardboard they're
clearing 69 billion dollars they're
they're making more money than the
farmers are okay we're spending more
money on the packages our food comes
from than on the farmers so we can't
expect them to drive this change that's
too much to ask it's really that seven
hundred and seventy billion dollars of
food marketing food processing which is
to say convenience eating so they're you
know the farmers are not the decision
makers here to a large extent it's it's
about policy and it's about us and that
means changing our behavior we need to
enlist more people in this movement and
that's why I think what Michelle Obama
is doing is so important we need to
begin with our children we need you know
Alice Waters really got this one right
the fact is that the way you begin to
change the food culture is teach
children how to grow food how to cook
food and how to eat food now that might
sound a little paternalistic that our
schools should be teaching children how
to eat and that strikes parents as odd
but make no mistake we're teaching them
how to eat right now if you give kids
for lunch chicken nuggets and tater tots
in ten minutes to eat them in you are
teaching them very effectively how to
become a fast food consumer for the rest
of their lives so we need to teach them
in a different way
so I think reform of school lunch which
is very much on the agenda this year
there the school lunch reauthorization
is coming up is is vitally important we
need to bring back home ACK we need to
make as Alice Waters says make lunch an
academic subject I think she's
absolutely right about that
now we also need to teach adults because
the great many adults are not aware that
they're eating fossil fuel they think
they're eating hamburgers and french
fries and you could see how they might
make that mistake it looks more like
hamburgers from French fries than fossil
fuel so we have to make it look make it
look a little more like oil and the way
you do that I think is you put a second
calorie count on every package of
processed food that there are you know
60 calories of food energy in this head
of lettuce or whatever it is and a
hundred and sixty calories of
fossil-fuel energy so you can know at a
glance are you eating something that
took more fossil fuel energy than solar
energy to deliver to you and if we put
that on every food package at least
those people who care would be educated
about what's really going on
we need much more that's one example of
a whole raft of measures to make the
food system more transparent the fact is
people really are deeply disconnected
from where their food comes from and
it's very hard to find out the products
all lie there are you know images of
farms and pastoral scenery on the
packages of that really are coming from
feedlots when the food system gets this
long and this opaque it's very hard to
know what kind of system you're really
supporting and consumers are deeply
confused so I think we need to move
toward a system where there will be a
second barcode on every product I know
I'm crowding these labels and that and
that you could run that barcode under a
scanner at a kiosk in the supermarket
and there would come an image of the
farm where that chicken actually live
[Applause]
this is no longer expensive at all and
you would see the dot you press another
button and see the diet what did that
chicken eat what and what what
pharmaceuticals went into that chicken
and then you press another button and
you see the slaughterhouse and nothing
would clean up those awful places faster
then cameras broadcasting through the
web to eaters on a 24/7 basis so we
should be fighting for transparency the
principle of the glass abattoir the
glass wall in the slaughterhouse you
know will will be more powerful than any
regulation you could dream up and then
of course we need and I and I propose
this in farmer in chief and and I've
been very happy to see that it's
actually happening
is that the White House set an example
and Michelle Obama has begun to do that
we have a White House organic garden
which is you know very who thought that
this would actually happen except for
Alice Waters actually but I never
thought it would really happen you know
this sounds symbolic but if you go back
to World War two when Eleanor Roosevelt
did the same thing we got to a point
where there were 20 million Victory
Gardens in America in World War two and
they provide for tea they provided 40
percent of the produce in this country
we have this huge resource called the
great American lawn and to the extent we
can rip that out and begin growing food
that is the most local food of all that
is the shortest food chain of all the
freshest most nutritious and often
tastiest food that you can possibly grow
but gardening is very very important for
other reasons too and I'm going to end
on this point and talk a little bit more
about politics perhaps when we sit down
because gardens teach a different way of
being in the world a tremendous part of
our problem I think confronting climate
change today is that we all feel
helpless it's too big a problem and our
lives are just too deeply woven into
this system of what Wendell Berry called
the cheap energy mind
by that he meant
we do so little for ourselves today we
depend on distant others to feed us to
entertain us
to do our taxes to do everything and
it's only it's cheap fossil fuel that
allowed us to have this incredible
division of labor it is under written
some good things but the challenge of
living without cheap fossil fuel is the
challenge of doing more for ourselves
and the wonderful the wonder of
gardening is the discovery that doing
something more for yourselves is
eminently doable eminently pleasurable
and makes you feel empowered and I think
that finally is what's driving this
whole food movement it is one area of
our lives where we can take back power
from the cheap energy culture and even
if it's incremental even if it's in
parts but we see how we can do it we
don't see how we can live without our
cars without our heat without our air
conditioning but we can change the way
we eat and and begin really to tackle
these problems one delicious bite at a
time thank you very much thank you
thank you thank you
got some questions yes we do I think we
have more questions than we've ever had
that means I left some things unanswered
while you were talking I was thinking of
the Amish I have a particular interest
in the Amish and in many ways they would
satisfy a lot of your concerns of this
model of bringing animals back on to the
farm and what's interesting about the
Amish is that they're producing it
themselves at a great rate and they're
buying up farm land do you is are they
solution to the labor problem this is a
trap Gavin you know Wendell Berry talks
a lot about the Amish and many of his
examples of really good farming are
Amish the Amish are terrific farmers
they show what you can do with small
amounts of land sometimes really not
great land and how much food you can
produce without you know all the
technologies of modern agriculture but I
tend to think that the future of
Agriculture is not about turning back
the clock and the kinds of Agriculture
that excite me are not pre-industrial
they're post-industrial and so what
someone like Joel Salatin is doing with
these very complex rotations of animals
depends on a knowledge of entomology
soil science botany energy flows that
simply was unavailable but until very
recently and so to hold up the Amish as
an example even though I think there's
there are many things to be learned from
them and and Wendell Berry has
translated a lot of those lessons is to
is is to suggest that we need to turn
back the clock and and I don't think
that's what I don't think that's what's
in store okay so you talked about the
kind of post-industrial solutions so
Anthony Cagle I think that is what is
the role of robotics in real ouka lysing
agriculture that's a good one
well you know one of the
when you look at a monoculture you
realize it's tied to a certain kind of
technology which is to say the the you
know the big combine the 32 row plant or
these are amazing devices and
monoculture seems to favor that kind of
simple one solution technology but I was
talking to an agronomist at Iowa State
when I was researching Omnivore's
Dilemma and he said you know that's that
fit was true once but it needn't be true
now and there is no reason that we
shouldn't be able to develop a
mechanical picker that could handle
something like the three sisters
rotation of you know the Mexican
rotation of corn squash and beans and
things right beneath different times
that you know if they can build cars
they can recognize when the tomato is
right when the beam is ripe and actually
sort their way through that complicated
little ecosystem going on there so you
know it's it's a high capital solution
but I think that we are at a moment
where we could start reconceiving our
our hardware in agriculture to deal with
poly culture so if he'll fund it I'll
support it Fred no last name cheap food
is also very convenient and fast eating
real food requires time and effort given
our time obsessed Society how do you how
do we affect what is a huge behavioral
change well that's the cultural shift
I'm talking about I mean we put very
little time into food in this country
it's something like a half hour a day
for procuring food preparing food and
eating food that's that's the average
it's not amazing how little time it is
this used to occupy many many hours and
most people feel they don't have anymore
time to give to food I find this kind of
stunning I mean in the last 10 years
alone we found 2 hours a day to deal
with the Internet the day is still 24
hours there's no more time in the day
now we're stealing this from our
employers in many cases I think but we
could steal a little online food
shopping too so I really think it is for
many people about priority and I know we
have you know we have to income
and it is more of a struggle but we
spent a lot of time waiting in
restaurants for our food to be prepared
and if you throw that time in that all
at that time could be spent cooking
there are a number of questions about
your kind of avoidance of the issue of
genetically engineered food and
particularly as you were suggesting that
you're not interested in looking back
but going forward so what's wrong with
genetically engineering crops to produce
the kinds of things that we want in
whatever direction that we want to go
well I can imagine genetically modified
crops that would contribute to the kind
of sustainable agriculture that I'm
describing we don't have them now
and they're not and by and large they're
not being worked on
I mean Pam Ronal and they tell you
something else when she comes here but
basically technologies don't operate in
isolation they're they're contextual and
the context of the big GM crops we have
today are mono cultures they are
designed specifically I mean all the
money goes into corn and soy more corn
and soy Roundup Ready soy BT corn or now
Roundup Ready corn and essentially what
we're using GM to do is to allow farms
to monocultures to get even bigger one
of the mysteries of genetic engineering
and you should ask Ron and Pam ronald
about it is that you know if you read
the back page ads of monsanto they
talked about you know we need we need
genetic engineering to increase the
yield because we have a fixed land base
10 billion people coming we need GE to
increase yield that sounds good but look
at the history the history of GE they've
been at it for 20 years they have not
increased yield that's not what they do
ask a farmer and they will say no it's
not about increased yield what it's
about is I can handle more land because
I don't have to do the three Springs of
herbicide I can handle more land because
if there's an outbreak of European corn
borer over there I'm covered I don't
even have to pay attention to it because
the plant will put out the pesticide so
the thing to be to be careful about and
this is what I would have talked to
Stuart about is that a lot of GE is
being sold to us based on a future
promise that I don't even think they're
working on we are being celled a pig in
a poke with to use a farmer expression
that I don't even understand
I meant to Google that what is a poke
what a bag it's a bag thank you okay
it's it's it's the right analogy we're
being sold genetically modified seed in
a poke you know if if Monsanto is really
serious about using its crops to solve
problems they won't be working on
basically what are essentially band-aids
on monocultures so you know I think we
talk altogether too much about it I
think it gets way too much attention and
that's why I didn't talk about it but
the the increases in yield we have seen
over the last 20 years have all been
from conventional breeding which is
withering on the vine because it doesn't
get support but there we can solve these
problems with conventional breeding so
I'm not raising alarms about the health
risks I'm not even raising alarms about
the environmental risk although there
are some what I'm suggesting is that
this is really a very good business for
a small handful of companies and that
the real key to genetic engineering is
control of intellectual property of the
food crops that we depend on this is why
they do it and if we had open source
genetic engineering if we had genetic
engineering that was really being
applied to making the system more
sustainable rather than more brittle
which is essentially what it's doing you
know I I'm open to learning about it you
know it's possible I mean maybe you can
figure out a way to increase the
photosynthetic efficiency of plants but
the other thing I would insist on
besides open source
for the intellectual property is freedom
to study it and one of the real you know
Monsanto and these companies say that
this is the most he got me started on
the story I do a lot to say that you
know this is the most studied most
regulated food in history the fact is
that you as an independent scientist are
not allowed to study a monsanto product
you are simply forbidden and if you want
to do a test on the environmental or
health implications of genetically
modified soy or corn or whatever you
must sign a contract that gives Monsanto
a prior approval before you can publish
and just two months ago crop scientists
around the world signed a letter saying
we can't study this stuff and we need
the ability to you know really shine the
light of science on this thing and not
let Monsanto control all that
information so those are my objective by
the way Stewart if you want to read and
I'll turn at a point of view
Stewart's new book has two very powerful
but completely wrongheaded chapters on
this but they're well worth reading they
will focus them on Stewarts book Stewart
Stewart spoke will be out in October and
he will actually be giving a long now
seminar on his book in October so come
back in October this is a question from
cameo wood as a beekeeper I am
constantly asked by farmers to put hives
on their pesticide treated farms my bees
die and they hire new PG burs how can I
help farmers break this cycle
yeah well the bee issue is is is very
alarming you know we've been talking
about the system being unsustainable for
a long time and the question of where
the breakdown would occur you know who
knows and it probably will happen in
some very unpredictable way it might be
the loss of cheap fossil fuel but it
might be the collapse of the honeybees
on which we depend for what one and
three of every jar of bites of food we
take the problem with the bees is
basically there is a monoculture problem
a lot of people think that the source of
honey bee disease that so many of them
are you know this colony die-off has to
do with the fact that the bees are
spending time on pesticides soaked
fields but more important they're all
coming to California every February to
pollinate the almond harvest the almond
crop every Valentine's Day 75% of the
bee hives in America are driven across
country to the Central Valley because
there are so many almonds there and
everyone every blossom every almond you
eat needs to be pollinated by honeybees
and there simply are not enough
honeybees in the Central Valley why
because there's nothing to eat for 50
weeks of the year why would they hang
out so they have to bring them in and
this practice only began in the 70s when
you know is $10 to rent a box of bees
now it's a hundred and fifty dollars to
rent a box of bees that's how critical
the need is so that you have people
waking up bees in New England driving
them across country get this to get them
in shape they give them high fructose
corn syrup
I'm not kidding we are giving bees high
fructose corn syrup so they will be you
know sturdy enough to attack the almond
crop and and since we're bringing bees
from all over the country and
increasingly all over the world because
we didn't have enough bees three years
ago so the USDA allowed them to import
bees from Australia who had a new set of
diseases that American bees hadn't been
exposed to we mix them all up and the
beekeepers called the great bee bordello
in the Central Valley so you know we
need to plant bee habitat where we have
our crops you know if you're gonna be
growing almonds you know a certain
percentage of your land has to be
devoted to you know wildflowers or
whatever the bees want to stay healthy
for the rest of the year so one of the
things that's very evident these days is
that more and more China and other
countries like India are having a larger
effect on the world in terms of whatever
it is that we want to count whether it's
pollution or generation of gases or even
economic are there other countries of
the world and this is a question for
Michael M
whose functioning the modern functioning
agriculture systems they were good doing
a good job that you think are worth
looking at so is China doing anything
that we should be paying attention to or
is it things that we shouldn't be doing
are they imitating us so how does this
fit into the global view yeah well you
know I have to say it's I have not
worked on the global question that hard
and so I'm speaking more from what I've
read than what I've seen by and large
other countries are following our lead
because we you know we've basically
insisted they do that
a free trade has been by and large in
agriculture a process of breaking down
local agricultural systems so that we go
to Africa when we say if you want to
renegotiate your debt part of structural
adjustment is no more grain Reserve
grand reserves are very powerful tools
for a government to keep food prices
from getting too high or too low and
that was something I didn't mention but
we need to bring back rain reserves the
the grain traders hate it because they
lose the ability to speculate but it's
probably very important we go to a
country like Malawi and we say no you
can't give fertilizer subsidies to your
people anymore that's market distorting
so we have countries that have been
pretty good at feeding themselves and
that we have insisted that they throw
themselves on the mercy of global you
know grain markets and I think that that
we learned last summer that that
probably was a mistake and the emphasis
is moving the other direction the World
Bank is encouraging countries to once
again build up their indigenous ability
to feed themselves I don't know that I
can point to countries they're really
great examples and in many countries of
sustainable growing that the example I
cited from Argentina is very interesting
although that is gradually being
disassembled for complicated reasons
that have nothing to do with its
effectiveness but just the policies the
government makes so much money on soy
experts they get 35% of the soy exports
that they're encouraging farmers to just
do soy every year China is not a good
model I mean China has polluted their
soil to such a great extent that they're
very high levels of heavy metals in
their food
there I would not trust any product
called organic from China I don't think
they really know what organic means and
I say that because my students have gone
to report on it and you know bought the
strawberries off the organic farms and
have them tested and found them full of
prohibited pesticides China has polluted
so much of its land in fact that they're
buying land all over Africa now they
realize they're looking ahead I mean
they're taking a longer view than we are
they're looking ahead and they said we
don't have enough land to feed our
people so we're gonna buy the best
agricultural land in Africa which will
be really popular in Africa there's a
question from Don Toffler does your big
agricultural system encourage the use of
recycled water municipal wastewater
treated to title Azizi standards so in
kind of urban farming it yes is the role
of water and water use and recycling
municipal grey water does that yeah it's
very important it's illegal in a lot of
places you know to recycle grey water
and and but if we're gonna have an
explosion of home gardens we have to
figure out systems to allow that
otherwise you know it will be
unsustainable at least in California I
mentioned will Alan he's his system in
Milwaukee is an ingenious has an
ingenious water angle which is that he's
growing fish these golden perch and he
grows them in tanks in these unheated
greenhouses they're essentially heated
by the compost piles that there's one in
each corner that's enough heat and the
the wastewater from the fish that they
produce their waste filters down that
water is brought around and that water
then goes to the plants feeds the plants
gives them all the nitrogen they need
they essentially clean the water by
taking up the nitrates and then the
water comes back it cleaned to the fish
so it's a closed-loop system and we can
design those systems I mean permaculture
this is this is what I'm describing as
permaculture has
you know is always very sensitive to the
water issue but we we simply need to you
know we don't price water properly to
make people take care of it
most of the water we're wasting is is
you know it's not you know yeah you're
teenagers long shower is one thing but
it's um it's it's the alfalfa crop in
California basically and it's 25 percent
of the water in California goes to grow
this low value water hungry crop that
then goes to feed dairy cattle living in
a desert
so you've in some ways pinpointed the
the root of the disease and the sickness
for the food system as being cheap
energy cheap fossil fuel and cheap water
we should have what if we had cheap
energy of a different type what if there
was cheap nuclear energy is it the fact
that it's cheap that's the problem or is
the fact to this cheap and fossil fuel
well I don't know how much that's a good
question I mean in terms of the climate
effect it's because it's fossil fuel
we're brighter and we're turning it into
things like fertilizer which you know
release nitrous oxide but if it was
cheap nuclear fuel would we be eating
but nukes ahead of eating oil but I
don't know how you would use that when
you talk about nuclear fuel you're
talking about electricity yeah and and
that's not an important input in
agriculture it might be in food
processing I suppose yeah if we put the
whole grid on on electric nuclear fuels
electric trucks for our yeah we would we
would definitely that would definitely
cut down on the carbon footprint of our
food but most of the carbon footprint of
our food has to do with the the you know
the fertilizers which I don't see how a
nukes help you with that and and you
could you could get that you could
squeeze the transportation part out but
I think that's probably about it okay so
here's a we haven't said anything
controversial here's a question from
Keith Borg how does hunting fit into
your idea of sustainable food well I
think that's a great question um you
know I think I think hunted meat is some
of the most sustainable meat
you can eat we haven't talked that much
about meat eating but as I've kind of
suggested if you want to do one thing to
reduce your carbon footprint cut down on
meat consumption
nothing is more produces more fossil
fuel that you do then eating lots of me
and I and I I think the idea of a
meatless Monday there's a movement to
start a meatless Monday is a terrific
idea
because it's something we could all do
it doesn't seem that hard I mean we we
can't have a day without driving for
many of us we can't have a day without
heating your house but we could have a
day without eating meat
that seems eminently doable and it's the
equivalent of taking 20 million cars off
the road 20 million mid-sized sedans if
everybody did it
hunted meat is solar produced meat right
I mean you know nobody's fertilizing the
the food that the deer are eating or the
or the wild boar and and we have a
surfeit of this of this meat so yeah I
mean I think that you know we need to we
need to appreciate what hunters can
bring to the table
so you mentioned politics here's a
question from Terry Moseley can you tell
us more about the folks that have been
put in charge of the Department of
Agriculture and the current
administration are they any good
would you prefer different people well
you know Tom Vilsack is the Secretary of
Agriculture and when he was first
appointed I gave a kind of you know
cranky and temperate response in an
interview and I said agribusiness as
usual he was governor of Iowa very close
to the biotech industry had you know
done some things in Iowa that weren't
that helpful but he surprised me and a
lot of other people since he's taken
office he's talked a lot about local
food he's talked a lot about farmers
markets he's very committed to building
farmers markets in this country and and
speaks about them with a passion that
comes from the heart and he really
understands that that farmers markets
are not just about food they're about
community it's become a very important
kind of new public square in America so
he will promote that he has as I said
he's hired as his number two Kathleen
Merrigan and I think that that's
incredibly helpful and already she's you
know started a program where we have
something called equip funds which is
money that in the farm bill that goes to
basically helping
feedlots clean up their waste we pay you
know they produce the waste we pay them
to clean it up that some of those funds
now can be used to help farmers
transition to organic that's a radical
new idea so I'm I'm encouraged by you
know some of the things are happening
he's really up against it and the
industry you know he made a move on
subsidies in the budget where they tried
to cut subsidies to farmers grossing
more than five hundred thousand dollars
a year and he and he depicted it as you
know taking money from rich farmers and
giving it to hungry children which is a
really not helpful way to describe it
because first of all they weren't rich
farmers I mean the problem with this
industry I'm describing is it's so
capital intensive that you could have
five hundred thousand dollars in gross
sales and be making forty thousand
dollars so he it was kind of not well
thought out and and it was promptly
dropped any or any unified the farm
block against him but I you know I do
think that there is pressure mounting
and that they feel that there is
pressure but it's important to
understand I think that it won't happen
you know I read that quote from Obama
and he gets it and it's not enough to
elect someone who gets it getting it is
not the same as doing anything about it
and Obama has actually said you know
privately to people he's talked to about
these issues you know I don't see enough
of a movement yet to move on these food
questions I'm show me the movement he's
used those words which FDR and used also
in other contexts show me the movement
and what he means is that you know there
was such opposition to change the system
works so well for such powerful
companies that he's gonna need a lot of
people at his back and there's a story
told about Bill Clinton in 1993 when he
when he when he he had his first budget
negotiation and he really you know was
kind of taken to the cleaners and gave
up a lot of his social investment Robert
rice Ian's ideas and kind of moved
toward the Robert Rubin side of things
and there was some good things in that
first budget but there were a lot of
things that disappointed people and at
the bill signing he found Bernie Sanders
in a corner and Bernie Sanders being the
the congressman furthest to
his left right the Socialist from
Vermont and he went over to him and he
started doing this thing with no he was
so good at Clinton would get people in
corners and you know and he said why
weren't you screaming at me I needed you
to be screaming at me so I could have
brought you something back so as much as
you might support Obama and I don't mean
to make any presumptions about the
politics in a San Francisco Hall like
this you need to scream at them we
really need to keep the pressure on
that's how change comes this is a note
from Brian Fisher who actually is a
world-class and expert who is offering a
challenge and expert ant expert at the
Cal Academy Sciences it says ants
invented farming 50 million years ago
they were fungus growing ants like leaf
cutter ants and they grow one species of
fungus they're growing a monoculture so
perhaps there may be something that you
we can learn from ants that's a great
question how do they do it how do they
how do they deal with disease I'm sure
Brian is here maybe you Ryan thank you I
want the answer to that question
so actually you know DuPont would really
like this even more than me so this is a
seminar on thinking long term as you
kind of imagine the future of the food
system give us a success scenario the
victory state in 50 years from now your
tireless talks and book writing has
succeeded and people have made a
movement and change has happened what
does it look like in this modern world
where we have the internet and beyond
and we have China and India rising do
you have you had you have a sense of
what agricultural system looks like that
is actually working well when I think
about the future I I imagine a time
where there will not be one agriculture
system where there will be more than one
I you know on a 50
horizon I don't see industrial
agriculture vanishing and I'm not even
so sure that would be a good thing for
it to vanish I think you know coming up
with one solution is another form of
monoculture thinking and that we would
make a mistake to throw all our eggs in
one basket whether it was pastured meat
or organic agriculture or any number of
different things we need a resilient
system which is to say with many many
different ways of doing the same thing
you know Joel Salatin when I asked him
the same question I said how do you see
the future what's you know are you gonna
blow up this is this industrial food
system and he said no I see it he's a
very religious man so he uses this
metaphor he said I see it as more of a
Reformation than a revolution which is
to say you know there used to be only
one way to feed yourself you know when I
was a kid there was the Industrial it
was the Church of industrial food it's
the supermarket it's where you got your
food there was no other place to get
your food and but then these reformers
came along and they nailed their
ninety-nine theses up on the church door
and suddenly you had all these new
denominations of food and we have that
we have organic we have pastored we have
local we have you know CSA movement we
have all these different urban
agriculture and we have choice and the
big church is still there but it's
smaller and that so and I think that's
about right I look forward to a day
where industrial food is a much smaller
part of the of the equation and that
these other systems are really vital
giving it a really good run for its
money competing successfully and and and
democratizing the choices obviously
because we haven't talked about that but
that's you know these choices right now
are more expensive there will be certain
struts pulled out from under industrial
agriculture for example the use of
antibiotics and livestock production
that is not we can't do that any longer
we can't afford it we don't have enough
antibiotics and they're gonna ruin the
ones we have so when we take that away
from them they'll probably change so
there will be changes within the
industrial side too and if we move
toward the kind of transparency I'm
describing
and really like blow open the doors on
these companies to they will change so
there would be positive change within
industrial agriculture and it's
happening already I mean even McDonald's
is you know feeling pressure from PETA
and it's changing the way they raise
animals
so you'll have you know incremental
change within but more importantly
you'll have all these choices without
and and that's what I look forward to
and and from a policy point of view
obviously policies that reward this
pluralism you're a journalist journalist
get bored thinking about the same thing
for very long what's next after
reforming the world the world's food
afterwards well I think I'm gonna be
busy with that for a little longer I
don't know I'm in the process of you
know dreaming up the next book ideas I
mean they're they're a little too young
to be trotted out in public and but I'm
working on some ideas and and writing
about some other things I mean you're
right I mean I don't want to just write
about food though my last project is I
did a piece for National Geographic on
the really kinky sexual practices of
orchids and you shouldn't be they're
really amazing and I went to Panama and
Sardinia and looked at how these orchids
reproduce and so I you know I I hope to
you know I have a lifelong love of
writing about plants and their and their
affect on us and and ingenuity so so
I'll be doing articles on other topics
right now I'm writing an article on
cooking and specifically cooking on
television the strange phenomenon of how
we managed and turn cooking into a
spectator sport in this country
what is what is that about you know if
you want to find time to cook the time
you spend watching cooking on television
[Applause]
well thank you for a wonderful thanks
for those excellent question
[Music]
you